That's all I'd like to say about shortest paths and weighted graphs in this unit.
There's some I think interesting questions on the homework
for you to get to know this concept better and to work with it and apply it
to some interesting social networks.
I'm going to take this last topic for this unit to be estimating the clustering coefficient.
This is kind of a different idea but I wanted to introduce the idea
of a randomized algorithm and we did that a little bit in the context of the expected
linear time top K algorithm.
And in that case, the answer that it returned was always the correct answer.
But the time that it took was actually a random variable that on average was linear
in the size of the list.
We're going to now look at computing the clustering coefficient approximately.
This is a really useful thing to do if the exact answer doesn't matter very much
which often when you're doing social network analysis it doesn't really
matter that much exactly what something like the clustering coefficient is.
You want to just get the ballpark whether it's heavily clustered or loosely clustered
or slightly more clustered than the movie database or not.
So just getting it correct to a couple of digits is probably sufficient.
But for the case of the clustering coefficient,
getting the exact answer is actually pretty expensive.
So just to remind you, here's some code for computing the clustering coefficient
of a graph with respect to a particular node v.
So given a node v or computing the clustering coefficient involves
looking at all the neighbors of v, going through them one by one,
and looking at the pairs of the neighbors.
And for each pair of neighbors, it does a calculation to compute how connected it is
and then returns a measure of how densely connected the neighbors are.
But that's for each node we need to look at the square
of the degree to actually compute this
So if the degree is rather high if the graph is fairly densely connected
or even if there's just a few nodes that have a very, very high connectivity
like maybe not that many edges, like a star graph for example.
The star graph has just linear number of edges
but it also has linear degree at least in that one node.
And so computing the clustering coefficient for that node is n²
well I guess in this case then the total running time is not going to be n³
because we don't have n² on each of those nodes.
But the running time is still pretty high and n² is pretty high.
And if this is actually a densely connected graph like a clique,
we're talking about n² for each of the nodes in the graph
which totals up to n³ and n³ for something like the Marvel Comics graph
where you have 6000 nodes, 6000³ is a pretty substantial number
even by current computing standards.
So we'd like to have a way of getting a pretty good answer in time a lot less than this.
Here's kind of a formula for the clustering coefficient.
In the clustering coefficient of a graph, you have to sum all the nodes in the graph.
We're going to average it for the n nodes in the graph.
And then for each of those nodes what we do is we sum up for all the pairs of nodes
that are neighbors of the node v.
We sum up whether or not they're connected and then we scale that by
taking the number of possible connections--
2 over the neighbor size of v times the neighbor size of v minus 1.
So would you think for a second about this random process that I've got this brace around here.
So imagine that we choose a v at random from anywhere in the graph
and then we choose a pair of neighbors of that particular chosen node v
completely at random from the graph.
And then we return either 1 or 0 depending whether those two nodes are connected.
What is the average value of this quantity?
And remember the average we're taking here is the average
over these two sources of randomness that we're randomizing
the overall nodes in the network and we're randomizing the overall pairs.
So just to review the expected value of some random variable x is the sum
of all values that the variable can take on, the value of that variable times the probability.
So for example for a six-sided die, the expected value that we get by rolling the die
it's the sum over all sides, the probability of getting that side which is a 6,
times the value on that side which is the numbers 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, or 6.
And so from that we can actually get the average value
that comes up on the die or the expected value.
So given that and if we're given a v, what is the expected value of c[wx]?
Maybe I should ask you. So here's a skeleton to get you started.
I'd like to know the expected value of the c, this connectivity variable, given a graph g
and a node v of that graph and I'll predefine for you the set of neighbors of v
and then the degree of v, the number of neighbors, the expression x in g(w) is true
if x and w are connected in the graph.
So those are the pieces that you need. Calculate this value exactly.
The expected value of the connectivity of w and x
for uniformly and randomly selected w and x from the set of neighbors.
So write that code and we'll test it for you.